hey guys how's it going real well
Comicon craziness right now are you
excited for next year there would be
lots of Punisher cosplay walking around
come on and that's not that hard to do
you just need like a good dark black
vest and spray paint if Frank could make
it with his kids arts material carotid
arts and crafts materials than anyone
can do it right right right
we did actually just get the official
first look at the Punisher costume it
was teased at the very end of the most
recent defenders trailer talk to me
about that costume did you have any
input at all in the look you know they
don't really listen to me about anything
yeah I'm like the last person that they
listed you know I think that you know
there was a lot a lot of time and effort
put into that and it wasn't just for the
aesthetics but there's as you know it's
very stunts heavy and you've got to be
able to move and I think what we try to
do is try to anchor everything in
authenticity and you don't want to put
anything on that you can't move in that
you can't fight it and that's really
important to me as far as the fighting
on the show one of the things that's so
amazing about the defenders is that it
initially wasn't in the original Marvel
lineup for the Netflix shows but the
fans resonated so much with your
character that they broke you out and
give you your own series what does that
mean to you I mean it it means the world
to me I just just really don't want to
let them down
and and you know the character means a
lot to me and it's it's a character that
resonates deeply in the law-enforcement
community and the military and
comic-book fans and I you know I along
with dev I mean the the best thing we
got going for us is right there and I
feel I just I just desperately hope that
we can get it right you know like Karen
and Frank never met in the comic book so
that was an interesting thing that jag
and Marco decided to do in our second
season of daredevil and I just I'm like
she's really grateful that they decided
they saw that there was a connection
there and the characters clicked and we
clicked and that you could invite Karen
and that storyline to be a part of
Punisher I'm just so glad I got to do it
love that I'm gonna shoot you
down with me ever so slightly I know
right
eg at comic-con now Deborah when we last
saw Karen she actually had just
discovered the truth that spoiler alert
matt is daredevil
where is she in her relationship with
him as she moves into the defenders are
we could have seen her at all shoot
about that I would really like to but
it'll be more fun of you watching I
think yeah I mean I think you know
they've done a lot of lying to one
another and they've got some healing to
do hopefully that will happen as you
guys said it was really good that was
really good sir that sort of works crow
right here as you guys said your two
characters never met in the comics so
how did you guys go into their chemistry
together what did you want to have of
their friendship on the show
look you know the most exciting thing to
me about about working with a great
actor is what sort of develops in the
chemistry that develops naturally and we
found you know with with Deb she's sort
of the one person that I can kind of
show up and I know I'm gonna get so much
from and I don't have to make a whole
bunch of decisions beforehand because I
know I'm gonna get a lot and you know
I've said it before it's it's it's it's
an honor and a joy to work with her
because she's so smart and so talented
and and there's a reason why Marvel is
sticking her in every single show you
know she's one she's she's just she's
something else and it's yeah I was it
was the best news it was better news
that she was going to be doing the show
and that there was going to be a show
and that's completely honest it's true
well no and I obviously can throw all of
that right back yeah you gotta do it no
I can't but the main thing for me is I
remember because we had met unlike the
first row second episode but you were
just like a ominous dark figure in the
background and our first day of really
working together you were like strapped
down to that bed and I remember thinking
like they wanted me to stand back and it
was awesome
No
want to get in his face and I want to
like if Jonah are gonna do this to the
rest of the season I want and but it was
great that it was they were really
scenes we didn't start off with
something unconnected we really had to
look at each other's eyes and find
something it was a great first episode
together how would you describe Frank's
journey in this first season
what's his mindset like look you know
the the front Castle that you saw on on
daredevil I think he wasn't the Punisher
you know he wasn't using man that was
still very much reeling from this you
know the most traumatic experience of
his life and I think what we'll try to
explore in this first season don't even
know if I'm allowed to say it but I'm
just making it up as I go anyway I can't
say it you can spill all the spoilers to
view it there Marvel tractor is it a
tractor beam or tracking beam anyway
does shoot meet with something no I feel
like yeah I feel like there's a sniper
like through that window right now III
think this will be very much about you
know how he sort of continues to go
about living a life and and and I think
that when you play play a character
who's put so much time and effort into
sort of building a wall around his heart
and closing himself off you know what
happens when light starts to shine
through that that wall a little bit on
the costume Frank is covered in his own
armor then he gets to put on a really
cool costume she does talk to me about
the first moment that you put that on
when you saw yourself in the mirror in
the full punisher outfit look you know I
just want to you know I I again fanboy a
little no I mostly just want to see that
I can still move and that I can get all
access to all my weapons it sounds so
corny but that's that's you know that's
really what I think pretty tactically
about about stuff like way too much it
takes you out of it a little bit so
there's a part of us that even though
you want to geek out you also want to go
no no no but these are real people
they're not archetypes any longer now
this is us and you can't get too geeky
about it or else you lose it
we'll just get kiki about it here at ET
lastly what is the one thing that you
want to say to the fans who really
resonated with the Punisher
I'm glad Frank's in your heart and she's
definitely in ours and you know I just
again I just I just hope we don't let
you down and we wanted to we you know
give it everything we got anything you
want to add oh gosh yeah I mean enjoy
the show I guess I think you did work
really hard on it and John's incredible
despite what he says he's amazing and
yes and just a joy to work with those
are the sweetest gather thank you so
much for stopping by really